well let's keep going with more examples
of function problems and and hopefully
as we keep doing this you're gonna
you're going to get the idea of how all
this stuff works so let's let's do
another problem I'm going to use green
this time let me clear everything so
I'll show you I showed you there one you
could define a function is just kind of
a standard algebraic expression you
could also do it kind of thing you know
if number is odd this is what you do if
a number is this is what you do you
could also define a function visually
let's let's say let me draw a graph and
I'll use a line tool so it's a
reasonably neat graph that's the x-axis
oh there oh that's pretty good and let's
draw the f of X axis or I mean you might
be used to calling that the y-axis but
it's okay oh I almost had it vertical
but let's see let's draw a few slashes
here and a couple of here like this
sorry for getting bored while I draw
this graph I should really have some
type of tool so that the graphs just
show up but let me draw a let's say that
let me draw this function so this is
what this is 1 2 3 4 5 this is negative
5 this is 5 this is 5 this is negative 5
and this is x-axis that's the x-axis and
this is we'll call this the f of X axis
now that might not seem obvious to you
at first but all this is saying is let's
say when X is equal to negative 5 this
function I'm creating a function
definition let's say it equals 2 that's
negative 1 it stays the same it's the
same
then it goes to here and then it goes to
here here and then see I hope I'm not
boring you and it just keeps moving up
let me see what this would this would
look like this
so if I you might think I'm doing
something very strange right now but I
just bear with me while I draw this I
hope I don't mess up too much and then
say it one like that say one like that
see with like Sal this is a very strange
looking graph and it is but what this is
is this is a function definition this
tells you whenever I input an X at least
for the X's that we can see on the graph
it this this graph tells me what f of x
equals so if X is equal to negative five
f of X would equal plus two right and we
could draw a couple of examples f of f
of zero well we go to zero on the x-axis
and we say f of 0 is equal to 0 f of 1
is equal to well we go to x equal to 1
and we just see where the chart is well
equals negative 1 right I think you get
the idea this isn't too difficult but
this is a function definition so this is
so we've defined this this graph right
here is f of X right so if that grad
that's the graph of f of X and let's say
that we define G of X G of X is equal to
f of X let's say it's equal to f of x
squared minus f of X and let's say that
H of X is equal to let's say that equals
to let's say it equals 3 minus X so what
if I were to ask you what is H of G of
negative
let's say of negative one so just like
we did in the previous problems first
we'll say well let's try to figure out
what G of negative one is and then we
could substitute that into H of X so G
of negative one so G of negative one is
equal to and this is how I do it there's
no trick to it you just never see the X
you just substitute it with the number
that you're saying is now the value for
X so you say well that's equal to F of
negative 1 squared minus F of negative 1
right all I did is is that G of negative
1 I just substituted it right wherever I
saw on X well what's F of negative 1
well when X is equal to negative 1 f of
X is equal to 1 so F of negative 1 let's
write that F of negative 1 is equal to 1
so G of negative 1 is equal to well
that's just 1 squared minus 1 well that
equals 0 right because F of negative 1
is 1 so it's 1 squared minus 1 that
equals 1 minus 1 is 0 so G of negative 1
is 0 so this is the same thing as H of 0
right because G of negative 1 we just
figured out is 0 H of 0 we just take
that 0 and substitute it here so it's 3
minus 0 so that just equals 3 and we
solve the problem let's do another
example and I don't want to erase my
graph since I took 4 minutes to actually
draw it let me erase what we just did
here and what you might want to do after
you watch it the first time and this
isn't true just of this video actually
of all the videos but especially on the
functions after watching it once you
might want to re-watch it and pause it
right after I give you the problem and
try to do it yourself and then see and
if you get stuck you can play it or if
you get an answer just you can play the
video and make sure that we did it the
same way let's see
let's say I'm going to create another
definition for G of X this time let's
say that G of X oh whoops
let's try and write in black let's say
that G of X is equal to F of x squared
is equal to f of x squared plus f of X
plus 2
alright so now in this case what is G of
let's pick a random number what is G of
minus now let's let's because let's say
what is G of minus 2 I have to make sure
I pick a number that we could find back
to a solution for well G of minus 2
wherever we see the X X is not going to
be minus 2 that is equal to F of minus 2
squared plus F of minus 2 plus 2 right
all we did is wherever we saw an X we
substitute minus 2 there and let's
simplify that well F of minus 2 squared
we know what minus 2 squared is that's
the same thing as F of 4 plus F of minus
2 plus 2 that's 0 plus F of 0 and now we
just figure out what F of 4 and F of 0
is well F of 4 we go where x equals 4 is
right here and when F when x equals 4 F
of 4 is equal to 2 so this is equal to 2
plus F of 0 well and just as a reminder
this is the definition of F we didn't
define it in terms of a function of in
terms of algebraic expression we defined
it in terms of an actual visual graph so
what's F of 0 F of 0 is 0 when X is
equal to 0 f of 0 is 0 so it's 2 plus 0
so G of negative 2 is equal to 2 an
interesting thing you might want to make
problems like this for yourself and keep
experimenting with different types of
functions and
very interesting thing would actually be
to graph G of X and actually that that's
a good idea I think I think maybe we'll
do that in a in a future modules to kind
of play with functions and then actually
to try to graph the functions and see
how they turn out
I will I don't know if I have enough
time actually I'm going to wait until
the next lecture to do a couple more
examples I want to do as many examples
on the functions as I can with you
because I think as you keep watching and
watching the function problems and and
seeing more and more variations on
functions you'll see both how general of
a concept this is and hopefully you'll
get an idea of how this the functions
actually work well I'll see you in the
next lecture have fun